so we have now learned that Golden Boy
Jared Kushner Donald Trump's son-in-law
was one of the twenty five-plus
individuals involved with the Trump
administration who was initially denied
a security clearance before someone
overrode it and he was ultimately
provided one along with access to
extremely sensitive information of
national security consequences as part
of this totally nepotistic advisory role
that he has for the President of the
United States so you might remember that
on the Tuesday show I came to you and I
said we now have testimony from an
official who has worked for Democrat and
Democratic and Republican presidents on
security clearances she testified before
the house and she brought documents and
testimony explaining that at least 25
people who sought security clearances as
part of the Donald Trump administration
were initially denied them until
political decisions were made with
influence from above that those
decisions should be overturned we
speculated I wondered because of
everything that's gone on with Jared
Kushner because of all of the deception
on his sf-86 financial disclosure forms
multiple times failing to disclose
foreign contacts and foreign visits and
all sorts of interactions with foreign
powers and agents and individuals all of
this very sketchy behavior with regard
to his security clearance to begin with
was Jared Kushner denied a security
clearance and ultimately got one and the
answer at this point
appears to be that yes he was to be very
very clear and I don't want to skip I
don't want to miss the forest for the
trees Donald Trump's son-in-law
shouldn't even be an adviser given that
he's Trump's family it's similar to
Trump's daughter Ivanka Trump working
for Donald Trump but she is and he Jared
Kushner also is and that's a massive
problem to begin with but then when we
catch wind that maybe he was denied a
security clearance and then it was
overridden and he was given one that is
even more acutely and
national security threat to the United
States caused by the Trump
administration and we can now say that
the answer is yes The Washington Post is
now reporting that Jared Kushner has
been identified as senior White House
official I believe he was named in some
of these documents as senior White House
official one or something like that
whose security clearance was denied by
career officials there are now documents
and testimony about Jared Kushner that
were provided earlier this week to the
House Oversight Committee Jared Kushner
applied for a security clearance
professional security experts looked at
Jared Kushner they determined that there
is too much foreign influence on him for
him to be cleared that there are private
business interests that could run
counter to those of the United States of
America and his involvement in access to
sensitive and classified documents and
that his personal conduct and I would
love to know more about what that means
also altogether required a denial of
Jared's security clearance the experts
research Jared Kushner and said no this
guy should not have a security clearance
but in comes this guy Carl Kline who's a
political operative who was heading up
the White House personnel security
office working directly for Donald Trump
and said I don't care what you found
approve it I'm paraphrasing this is the
bottom line said it doesn't matter what
you found we're approving Jared Kushner
security clearance we need to stop
playing any semantic games here if
Hillary Clinton were president and she
had Chelsea Clinton working for her and
it was revealed that national security
personnel security officials looked into
Chelsea Clinton and said you know what
we've got to deny her a security
clearance because she's influenced by
foreign power at foreign powers and her
personal conduct is concerning and her
private financial interests are
concerning and someone came in from
above and said for political reasons
Chelsea is getting the clearance Hillary
says Chelsea's getting the clearance
give Chelsea the security clearance this
would be bang
ozzie times 10 it would be nightly on
Sean Hannity it would be daily on the
Rush Limbaugh program it would be 24/7
on all of the right-wing forums and on
Facebook and the daily wire and Tucker
Carlson and all of this other stuff but
it's not Chelsea or Hillary Clinton it's
Donald Trump and Jared Kushner and
Ivanka and Republicans do not care
trumpets do not care they're hypocrites
but hypocrisy doesn't matter anymore
which is why we can't deal with them in
good faith they simply have to be
removed and I don't think we're over
blowing here the serious security
concerns this is not concern trolling as
there are people who like to claim these
are serious high-level security concerns
Kushner may be compromised this isn't
some lefty saying it this is someone
this is a department that specializes in
exploring these security issues they
looked into Kushner and determined he
might be compromised and instead of
having no role whatsoever to play in
American politics he ends up working at
the highest level of the White House the
entire Trump family is corrupt the
entire Trump administration is corrupt I
I mean do we have to be worried Trump
said Baron is really smart and does
amazing things with computers
what is Baron Trump being allowed to do
right now I'm sort of kidding but I'm
sort of not and the but her emails crowd
that wanted Hillary Clinton in prison
this is a massive national security
breach this is way way WAY worse than
Hillary's emails and I am open I'm
making an open call to people on the
right whether you're a trumpet or not
just take the intellectually honest and
intellectually consistent position here
that is that Jared Kushner needs to have
his clearance revoked Jared Kushner
needs to be removed from his position as
a Trump adviser and a full investigation
needs to happen here and I know that we
are long past the age where double
standards and hypocrisy matter the
hypocrisy matters when it comes to
Republicans but this is extraordinarily
disgusting that Hillary needed to be in
prison and we know what would have
happened if Obama or Clinton were ever
caught with something similar but it is
silence it is crickets that we are
hearing from the right on this issue and
I want to remind you of something else
because it's very easy to sort of forget
about the importance of the 20/20
election results were it not for the
20/20 midterms in which Democrats took
over control of the House of
Representatives we wouldn't know any of
this we wouldn't know if Republicans
continue to control the house and
Republicans continue to control the
oversight a House committee the
judiciary house committee all of these
committees we would have no idea that
Jared Kushner and two dozen others were
denied security clearances and for
political overrides got them anyway
that is why elections matter and at this
point there's one way to get these
people out there's one way we can make
damn sure that Jared Kushner does not
have access to highly sensitive
information in his role as an adviser to
the president
vote Trump out in November of 2020 you
now see why the 2018 midterm results
mattered and you can very quickly have
an impact on this garbage that is going
on by voting this guy out and everybody
who's around him in November of 2020
we've got a great program for you today
make sure you're following me on Twitter
at Dee Pakman make sure you're following
the David Pakman show on Twitter at
David Pakman show we will take your
calls I will answer questions I'll tell
you what's coming up on the program next
week we've got a little bit of a wacky
and different week on the show coming up
all of that and more glad you're with us
on this Friday show we all know and have
talked about how mentally exhausting it
has become to keep up with the news
lately because of everything that's been
going on over the last few years which
is why I'm so happy to tell you about
one of today's sponsors simple habit and
it's an app that gives you instant
access to thousands of really good
five-minute guided meditations and I
encourage you to try it for free by
going to simple habit dot-com slash
Pakman
each meditation on simple habit was
designed for a specific purpose like
waking up falling asleep dealing with
stress getting focused for work that you
have to do
I've really enjoyed integrating simple
habit into my day especially because
they just make it so easy
each meditation is just five minutes
long different meditations are catered
for whatever you're doing whether you're
driving to work or you're on your lunch
break or you're winding down for the day
we're constantly seeing new research
about how many benefits there are to
meditation and simple habit is the
perfect way for beginners to get started
with meditation but it's also just as
useful for people who already meditate
and want a library of guided meditations
right at their fingertips the app also
just won the 2018 Google Play award for
best well-being app I think almost
anyone could hugely benefit from an app
like this you can try it for free for a
week by going to simple habit calm slash
Pakman I've put a link underneath this
video